[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
jahrelang hielt ein ehepaar aus
nordrhein-westfalen in seinem haus
frauen gefangen sie haben diese frauen
durch kontaktanzeigen angelockt und sie
dann schwer misshandelt und verletzt für
zwei dieser frauen endeten die
grauenvollen folterungen tödlich ich bin
seit 34 jahren bild-reporter mit
schwerpunkt verbrechen
gerichtsberichterstattung ich habe über
tausende verbrechen berichtet aber der
fall höchster
so leitet der bild reporter markus
brekenkamp seinen bericht über eines der
abscheulichsten verbrechen der letzten
jahre 1 die fassungslosigkeit ist im
blonden und mit einem grauen t shirt
bekleideten reporter deutlich anzusehen
wenn er kopfschüttelnd über die
grausamen taten eines ehepaares aus
nordrhein westfalen berichtet
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen ausgabe von tatort
deutschland das horror haus von höchster
[Musik]
bild-reporter brickenkamp begibt sich zu
dem ort an dem die ermittlungen in gang
gesetzt wurden eine landstraße von der
ein wirtschaftsweg in den wald abbiegt
er steht etwas hilflos und sichtlich
erschüttert da und blickt sich um ja
hier in der b 64 in kleinen ländern den
südniedersachsen wollte am 21 april 2006
sind die aufdeckung eines der
schrecklichsten verbrechen der deutschen
kriminalgeschichte beginnen also genau
hier an der stelle wo ich jetzt bin ist
der opel vor einer damals 21 april 2016
liegengeblieben im auto saßen angelika
wagner ihren ehemann wilfried und auf
der rückbank lag eine sterbende frau
letztendlich war es ein zufall dass die
grausamen taten des ehepaars wagner
aufgeklärt wurden eine autopanne
angelika wagner entstieg dem fahrzeug
und alarmierte über ihr handy den notruf
die 20 minuten später eintreffende
ärztin kümmerte sich und die nicht
ansprechbare frau auf der rückbank sie
wies schwerste kopfverletzungen auf und
die körpertemperatur betrug nur noch 28
grad zwei stunden später verstarb die
frau im klinikum nord an
bei der versorgung der schwerverletzten
und schließlich der untersuchung der
leiche wurden schwerste misshandlungen
fessel male und eine kopfverletzung
festgestellt
diese war ohne zweifel durch äußere
gewalt entstanden solche entdeckungen
rufen selbstverständlich sofort die
ermittlungsbehörden auf den plan die
nachforschungen begannen dann trugen die
kollegin sechster inhalte der criminale
akte vor und dann hat ist eine
verurteilung 1089 gegeben irgendwie
grundlage waren massive quälereien einer
lebensgefährtin von ihm dafür haftstrafe
von fast drei jahren verbüßt und wenn
man das dann übereinander legt die
todesumstände von der beschädigten und
diese vorstrafen dann kommt man auch
nicht zu dem entschluss dass der
möglicherweise tatsächlich noch mehr
hinter stecken könnte
die in der presse veröffentlichten
bilder des horror paares gäben keinen
hinweis darauf zu welchen
ungeheuerlichen taten diese menschen
fähig sein sollen wilfried wagner wirkt
freundlich ein großer tapsiger bär der
viel lächelt es fällt schwer diese man
etwas böses zuzutrauen ein bild zeigt
ihnen die kamera schmunzelnd in kurzen
hosen mit einer ganz auf dem arm
angelika wagner dagegen bietet ein ganz
anderes bild sie wirkt ungepflegt
unscheinbar eine frau die auf ihr
äußeres keinen wert legt hier fehlen
einige zähne und die haare hängen
strähnig um ihr verhängtes gesicht
auch später vor gericht zeigt das
scheinbar so wenig zusammen passende
paar ein sehr unterschiedliches
verhalten wilfried wagner wird gelöst
lächelt seinen verteidigern zu sagt aber
zur sache nichts angelika wird sorgen
schwer in sich zusammengesunken und sehr
ernst aber sie macht umfangreiche
angaben und sie schiebt die schuld für
alle vorkommnisse auf ihren mann
aber zurück zu den anfängen dieses
unglaublichen verbrechens das ehepaar
wagner wird von der polizei aufgrund der
verdachtslage festgenommen die räume
ihres hauses werden durchsucht der
zuständige ermittlungsbeamte berichtet
wir mussten zumindestens davon ausgehen
dass diese sache mit der geschädigten
jetzt kein einzelfall blieb
grundsätzlich war jetzt mal die vorgabe
festnahmen in meinen personen bei dem
haus mussten jetzt gar nicht was auf uns
zukommt unseren g kwh die tür geöffnet
ich habe jetzt führungslos ausgehändigt
sie war die vorläufig festgenommen die
festnahme ausgesprochen sie belehrt
ich finde mit einem kollegen nach oben
gegangen habe wild gut angetroffen der
stand in unterhose vor seinem bett
ja ja war eigentlich fast gelassen also
zumindest nicht sagen dass er
konfrontation mit der polizei zumindest
gerechnet hat wer ist dieser mann der so
gelassen wirkt und solch grausame taten
begangen haben soll bild-reporter
bringen kann fährt mit seinen
dienstwagen nach bielefeld auf dem
beifahrersitz liegen unmengen von heften
vermarkten und ausdrucken mit denen er
sich auf das bevorstehende gespräch
vorbereitet hat er hofft von wilfried
wagners anwalt rechtsanwalt dr winder
antworten zu erhalten
in seiner kanzlei sitzt dr winter hinter
einem leeren gläsern den schreibtisch
und erinnert sich an seinen ersten
eindruck von seinem mandanten er spricht
sehr ernsthaft von dem mann der als
bestie von höchster bekannt werden
sollte
die tür geht auf und es kommt ein mann
entgegen der nahezu zwei meter groß ist
gefühlt 110 kilo wiegt also sicherlich
eine imposante gestalt darstellt der
aber dann ganz im gegensatz zu dem was
man erwartet freundlich ist zugewandt
ist zuhört und
das bild was man sich ja vielleicht über
die medien am anfang gemacht hat da gibt
es einen sadistischen täter das bröselt
in sich zusammen und man hat den
eindruck was macht er hier ist das
wirklich der richtige kann das wirklich
die person sein gegen die diese
schwerwiegende vorwürfe erhoben werden
allen verfahrensbeteiligten stellen sich
zunächst fragen über fragen wie verhält
es sich mit der ehefrau des täters
angelika wagner war sie an den
misshandlungen beteiligt war auch sie
täterin oder selbst opfer bild-reporter
bringen kann begibt sich erneut nach
bielefeld und besucht dort ein
unauffälliges eckhaus neben dessen
hauseingang ein einfaches schild zeigt
wen der reporter hier aufsuchen möchte
rechtsanwalt peter müller er war von
beginn des verfahrens an der verteidiger
von angelika wagner
hoch konzentriert und in wohlgesetzten
worten schildert er seine ersten
eindrücke von seiner mandantin die
später in den medien als hexe von
höchster bezeichnet werden würde
ein mandat zu übernehmen es habe
jemanden mir gefragt ich habe zugesagt
habe dann spontan für den nächsten tag
einen termin im präsidium vereinbart und
dort traf ich dann morgens das erste mal
auf angelika mich erschrocken weil sich
angelika damals in einem sehr schlechten
einem einem sehr desolaten
körperlichen
zustand befand die ihr ganzer körper war
übersät mit narben mit entstellungen sie
war sehr
ungepflegt er fehlten ganz viele zähne
sie war
zwar verhärtet sie war kalt da war
nichts warmes da ganz keine emotionen
sie hat der polizei ja von a bis z
erzählt was dort auf diesen kleinen
bauernhof in höchster bosseborn über
jahre hinweg stattgefunden hat
über jahre wurden frauen gequält
misshandelt und letztendlich getötet
aber wer waren die opfer wie kamen sie
ihr das haus der wagners warum sind sie
dort über längere zeit geblieben und
nicht bei der ersten gelegenheit
geflüchtet bild-reporter briten kam
berichtet von deren start in ein
unsägliches materie
dass diese frauen zunächst eingezogen
sind in der erwartung hier eine
liebevolle beziehung mit wilfried
wagener zu führen die frauen waren der
überzeugung dass die frau die dort mit
wohnt seine leibliche schwester seit
die ermittlungen ergeben später das sich
über die jahre fast 1600 frauen auf die
kontaktanzeigen von wilfried wagner
gemeldet haben von mindestens sechs
frauen ist bekannt dass sie in das haus
eingezogen sind zu dem paar das sie dort
gemeinschaftlich misshandelt und gequält
hat wilfried wagner und seine
vermeintliche schwester angelika
angelika wagen ist aufgewachsen auf
einem bauernhof
sie hat mir ganz ganz ganz ganz enge
bindung zu ihrem vater der dann aber
starb sie wird beschrieben als
grobschlächtige junge frau und sie hat
immer darunter gelitten dass sie keine
beziehung zu jung hatte und was macht
eine frau die auch nicht in discos geht
oder in kneipen und attraktiv ist die
reagiert auf partner anzeigen und ist
dann an willi wagner geraten das waren
anfang 1999 man weiß heute nicht die
innere wahrheit hinter dieser beziehung
die kennen die canon wenig genau ist war
jedenfalls so dass das ölfeld wagner
relativ schnell auch anfing sitzung des
handels
ortswechsel ein äußerlich
heruntergekommenes grau verputztes
bauernhaus mit scheune
gibt zunächst keinen hinweis auf die
grausamen ereignisse die sich in seinem
innern abgespielt haben
es ist das haus der eheleute wagner der
bild reporter erreicht durch einen
verwilderten gaben die polizeilich
versiegelte haustür brekenkamp betritt
den tatort das bild das sich ihm nun
bietet gibt sofort einen eindruck was
für menschen hier lebten von den wänden
bröckelt der putz offen herumliegende
müll kaputte im weg herum stehende
möbelstücke dreck und verwahrlosung wie
konnte man so leben
in diesem haus war ist kalt es war
unheimlich es war bedrückend was wir
dort gesehen haben wenn man da durch die
einzelnen räume gehen dann konnte man
sich sehr gut vorstellen wie es den
menschen die dort gelebt haben bzw die
dort festgehalten wurden gegangen sein
der reporter stolpert im halbdunkel fast
durch das haus kaum vorstellbar dass
sich hier frauen freiwillig aufgehalten
haben weshalb sind sie nicht beim ersten
anzeichen von misshandlungen geflüchtet
der anwalt von wilfried wagner sagt dazu
macht eigentlich mit den frauen eine
systematische hirnwäsche
die frauen werden scheinbar nicht
grundlos misshandelt nicht grundlos
geklärt sondern es werden immer gründe
vorgegeben erklärt den frauen das bist
du doch jetzt schuld du hast doch die
regeln nicht eingehalten du hast doch
die regel verletzt und chemiker setzt
irgendwelche regeln die nicht
einzuhalten sind es gibt 148 regel das
ist ganz offensichtlich von anfang an
offensichtlich dass diese frauen die
regeln nicht einhalten können
abstruse und in der summe niemals
umsetzbare anweisungen
hier ein paar beispiele
ausreden lassen nicht beim autofahren
stören keine große klappe haben zügig
antworten nicht aufstoßen
fleißiger sein draußen nicht laut sein
nicht abstreiten aber damit nicht genug
die regeln wurden auch angewendet wie
angelika 's anwalt erwähnt die polizei
hat im rahmen der
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen ja hunderte
videos
tondokumente sichergestellt ja auch
gegenstand der ermittlungen gewesen sind
es sind erschütternde aufnahmen die nur
in abgeschwächten auszügen
veröffentlicht werden können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück im haus der wagners betritt der
reporter das sogenannte katzenzimmer ein
raum voller unrat und müll an der wand
ein vergammelter heizkörper hier an den
verrosteten heizungsrohren wurden die
frauen in der nacht angekettet wilfried
wagner wollte nicht dass sie nachts
seinen leichten schlaf stören aber
wilfried war dann durch das klappern der
ketten zu genervt und die frauen wurden
in ein ungenutztes badezimmer im keller
verfrachtet
brekenkamp ist sichtlich angewidert wir
sind dann das war eigentlich das
schlimmste erlebnis in den keller
gegangen das ist so ein durchgangsraum
zur scheune dort gibt es auf der rechten
seite ein kleines badezimmer in dem eine
eine völlig verdreckte badewanne sich
befand man stellt sich vor wieder eine
eine frau die die sowieso schon in einem
ganz ganz schlechten körperlichen
zustand ist wie wir dort in dieser kälte
fast nackt angekettet und muss dort
nächte lang verbringen man weiß nicht
wie lange man das selbst durchhalten
würde man ahnt aber wie schnell eben der
körper einer solchen person das nicht
mehr mitmachen kann
in der badewanne verbrachte das erste
opfer annika w tage vielleicht sogar
wochen es ist bitter kalt und feucht sie
kann sich vor erschöpfung nicht mehr
selbstständig erheben und stirbt in
dieser eisigen heute
der haupt vernehmungsbeamte befragt
angelika wagner was mit dem opfer nach
dessen tod geschah
daraufhin schildert angelika sachlich
wie sie annika w entsorgt hat sie zeigt
die junge frau damit sie die
leichenteile besser in dem kleinen ofen
des wohnzimmers verbrennen kann auf die
frage wessen idee das war gibt der
anwalt von wilfried folgende
erschütternde antwort der schritt hat
sich komplett aus dieser frage ich nehme
es herausgehalten angelika sagt naja der
feine herr wollte damit nichts zu tun
haben und ich hatte die ganze
drecksarbeit schaut sich dann im
publikum möchte am liebsten applaus
dafür sind diese schwere
schweißtreibende arbeit ist gemacht
bild-reporter brickenkamp fährt zu einer
ehemaligen geliebten von wilfried wagner
im herbst 1999 war sie mit ihm zusammen
gekommen sie wurde schwanger und bekam
eine tochter von wilfried die frau heute
in den mittleren jahren mit grauen
kurzen haaren spricht offen über ihre
einstige beziehung zu wilfried wagner
die nur kurz währte
auf die frage woran die beziehung
gescheitert ist antwortet sie ja
er hat mich angerufen
ich hatte ja vorhanden
und dann er mir haben telefon nur gesagt
ich sollte das kind abtreiben erhöhte
mit mir nach holland fahren und dann
klar gesagt nein das mache ich nicht und
dann gehen gestand auch überhaupt keinen
kontakt mehr vielleicht hat diese
bestimmtheit er das leben gerettet
[Musik]
zurück am tatort direkt hinter dem
wohnhaus der wagners befindet sich der
schweinestall der nicht mehr als ein
völlig herunter gekommenes nebengebäude
ist absolut ungeeignet für tierhaltung
aber genau hier wurde susanne f
regelmäßig angekettet
zwanzigster april 2016 nach den aussagen
von angelika wagner befreite sie susanne
f aus der badewanne im keller half ihr
die treppe zur küche hinaufzugehen oben
sei susanne gestrauchelt und mit dem
kopf unglücklich auf die kante eines
küchenschrank gefallen klingt nicht
gerade plausibel denn anstatt den
rettungsdienst zu rufen brachte angelika
die junge frau wieder in die badewanne
im keller erst am darauf folgenden tag
soll angelika bemerkt haben dass die
schwerverletzte susanne f um ihr leben
kämpft die unglaubliche entscheidung des
horror paares was man nun tun wolle
beschreibt angelika 's anwalt
mit annika die erfahrung damit was mache
ich jetzt mit einem toten menschen ich
habe eine leiche im keller im wahrsten
sinne des wortes ich muss eine leiche
entsorgen dass es arbeit
das ist stress und ist auch keine schöne
tätigkeit
deshalb kam man überein dass man susanne
am besten indem ganz ganz schlechten
körperlichen zustand wieder nach hause
bringt also dahin wo sie herkommt damit
susanne nicht in bosseborn geholt hat
welche menschen sind zu solchen taten
fähig der bild-reporter brickenkamp
reist mit diesem gedanken nach berlin
professor borwin bandelow ein
renommierter und international
anerkannte psychiater erwartet ihn im
axel-springer-haus der täter scheint ein
sadist zu sein der bezieht ebenso ein
lustgewinn heraus dass frauen um gnade
winseln und ich denke dass der täter
eine antisoziale persönlichkeitsstörung
hat das ergibt sich allein schon aus den
taten er hat ja diese frauen als
sklavinnen gehalten hat sie gequält und
hat kein mitgefühl und keine reue
gezeigt also die klassischen zeichen
einer hat die sozialen
persönlichkeitsstörung kein mitgefühl
und keine reue wilfried wagners anwalt
dr winter beschreibt wie sein mandant
geistig tickt wenn man will versagt wird
er sagen entschuldigung und sagte
entschuldigung genau wäre ein kleines
kind deswegen wenigsten entschuldigung
gab wenn er mal anschuldigung gesagt hat
dann hat er das gesagt weil ihm entweder
ein mitgefangener oder der pastor in der
jva oder sonst irgend eine bezugsperson
gesagt hat es ist immer gut sich und
prozess zu entschuldigen aber wirklich
verstanden was er falsch gemacht hat hat
er bis vor gericht
angesichts der ermittelten sachverhalt
drängt sich immer wieder eine frage auf
wer war hier anstifter und täter oder
noch ein opfer von abhängigkeit und
gewalt hat angelika wagner die
misshandlungen nur unter zwang
ausgeführt oder war sie die treibende
kraft bei den gemeinsam verübten
verbrechen angelika hat damals
einem satz gebraucht sie hat würde ich
gesagt wenn andere frauen im haus waren
hatte ich meine ruhe dann werde ich
nicht geschlagen werde ich nicht
gebissen da werde ich nicht in eine
decke eingewickelt da wird mir die luft
genommen da werde ich verbrannt
geschnitten und misshandelt wenn nämlich
eine andere frau aus war dann richtete
sich die aggression von
wilfried ihre partner in verschiedenen
ehemann nicht mehr gegen angelika selbst
sondern gegen das neue opfer und das ist
auch der grund gewesen warum angelika
gesagt hat ich unterstütze diese
bemühungen das neue opfer ins haus
kommen wilfried wagners anwalt stellt
sich dagegen die person die freude daran
hatte freude empfunden hat die frauen zu
quälen ist tatsächlich angelika gewesen
und angelika hat letztlich wilfried
ausgenutzt hat ihn im grunde zum
spielball ihrer fantasien gemacht mit
friendly ist äußerst unsicher ist devot
er ist unterwürfig wilfried kann nicht
unterscheiden zwischen dem was ist gut
was ist böse was ist richtig was ist
falsch
neben glauben und spielt das überhaupt
für die wahren opfer eine rolle haben
sich schlicht in diesem paar zwei
grausame individuen gefunden die sich in
ihrer verachtung anderen menschen
gegenüber ergänzte
sechs opfer litten unter angelika und
wilfried wagners quälereien und
misshandlungen zwei von ihnen überlebten
dieses material nicht
das urteil ist gesprochen und die
anwälte verlassen das gericht
angelika wagner wird vom landgericht
paderborn zu 13 jahren haft verurteilt
wilfried wagner zu elf jahren in der
psychiatrie
wilfried wagners anwalt dr winter stellt
sich den reportern auf den stufen des
gerichts
die strafe fällt niedriger aus als die
den bei der ehefrau das gericht hat
genau das anerkannt was wir immer gesagt
haben angelika ist die treibende kraft
angelika ist diejenige die die hosen
anhatte
in einigen jahren könnten sowohl
angelika als auch winfried wagner wieder
auf freiem fuß sein im hinblick darauf
macht die aussage des anwaltes von
angelika wagner zu winfried nachdenklich
ich würde ihn nicht
[Musik]
ich würde in diesen menschen als
gefährlich bezeichnet der mann wird das
immer wieder ton dieser man darf nie
unbeaufsichtigt gelassen werden
psychiater professor bandelow geht sogar
noch einen schritt weiter
persönlichkeiten eine extrem hohe
rückfallgefahr ist und das wird sich
auch aufgrund seiner niedrigen
intelligenz nicht so schnell ändern ich
denke auch nicht dass da eine therapie
in irgendeiner weise irgendwas ändern
kann das letzte wort über gebe ich an
den mann der für uns diesen fall so
aufwendig recherchiert hat markus
brekenkamp
an dieser stelle möchte ich danke sagen
dass hier wieder dabei war hat bei
tatort deutschland
bis zum nächsten mal sky dumont
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild produziert von den world studios
projektleitung lutz neumann und simone
terbrack produktion fabian schaeffler
und felix stehenbleiben bildredaktion
christine wahl frank schneider und
stefan netze
sprecher skyrim